this is nazanin zagari ratcliffe
arriving in the raf bryce norton in
oxfordshire
she is home
and a free woman
for six years she endured detention at
tehran's evan prison a hunger strike
house arrest and a brief release
followed by re-arrest three days later
now she can look forward to a future
with her husband richard who had
campaigned tirelessly for her release
and her daughter gabriella
i mean definitely
feeling a lot lighter um not sure i
quite believe it yet it still feels like
i mean i'm kind of in campaigning mode
but but yeah she's on a plane she's on
our home
this is almost over
and and
the whole family in iran are so much
more relaxed the whole family here have
been celebrating
um it's been a long journey it's been a
long journey that we've been in the
doorway for quite a long time
their audio began in april 2016 when
nazney was detained at tehran airport
while traveling back to london
she was arrested on charges of spying
which he always denied
after four years in prison she was put
under house arrests at her parents home
and was later sentenced to a further
year in detention with a travel ban
joining her on the flight anushi ashuri
a retired civil engineer
his family had also called for his
urgent release after he was arrested for
spying in 2017 a charge he denied
against this a question of a 530 million
dollar debt the uk owed for not
completing on a deal
it involved the sale of tanks and
military equipment to the then ruler the
shah
the foreign secretary liz trust
acknowledged the government had paid the
debt without contravening sanctions
imposed by western countries
what i can't do is go into the details
because that is confidential between the
parties but i have had this thoroughly
checked out
across government to ensure that we have
those guarantees that it will be used
for humanitarian purposes
now nazanin and her family will look
forward to a future together
laura barton manly al jazeera